hey this is presh talwalkar
avery and brian have the following
conversation
avery says
i'm thinking of two different one-digit
numbers
can you guess there's some
bryant responds
no
can you give me a clue
avery replies
the last digit of their product is the
same as your house number
brian then says
let me work it out
now i know
the question is what is the sum of the
two numbers
i thank pet for the suggestion and this
problem is adapted from a 2015 singapore
olympia challenge for primary five
students
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's enumerate the possible products of
two one-digit numbers
we'll create a little multiplication
table
now we're interested in the sum of the
two numbers
so we want to evaluate each product and
try to figure out the last digit of each
product
the lower half of this table
is identical to the upper half of this
table because multiplication is
commutative
two times one is equal to one times two
so we don't have to consider these
possibilities they'll be considered by
the numbers that are above the diagonal
next we know we have two different
one-digit numbers
so we can eliminate the diagonal
so now let's clean up our table
these are all the possible products that
we need to consider
avery had said the last digit of their
product is the same as your house number
brian replied let me work it out now i
know so we don't know brian's house
number
but we can work through the
possibilities
what if brian's house number was equal
to two
would he have been able to work out the
sum of the two numbers
the answer is no
there are many products that have a last
digit equal to two
and the two numbers have different sums
so brian's house number could not have
been equal to two he wouldn't have been
able to figure it out
what if his house number was equal to 3
well in one case we have 1 times 3 is
equal to 3 but in another case we have 7
times 9 is equal to 63.
so once again if brian's house number
was equal to three he wouldn't have been
able to figure out the sum of the two
numbers
we can then eliminate four because once
again we have many possibilities
so couldn't have been four it also
couldn't have been five there are many
possibilities brian wouldn't have been
able to figure out the answer
same thing goes for six
and we'll just continue to eliminate the
different possibilities
seven can also be eliminated
what about eight well again we have many
possibilities so it could not have been
equal to eight
now what about zero what if the last
digit was equal to zero that was brian's
house number well we have many
possibilities so we can again eliminate
this option
now what if brian's house number was
equal to nine
well there's only one case so it could
have been equal to nine
what if his house number was equal to
one
again we only have one possibility so he
would have been able to figure out the
sum of the two numbers
so we don't know if brian's house number
was equal to nine or it was equal to one
so how can we work out the sum
the interesting thing
is that these two cases have exactly the
same sum
1 plus 9 is equal to 10 and 3 plus 7 is
equal to 10. so while we don't know
whether brian's house number was equal
to nine or one we can definitively say
that the sum of the two numbers is equal
to ten
what an incredible puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you